the Fulani tribes people known for their
nomadic ways and for some of the world's
more painful rites of passage in a
remote region of northern benin west
africa the pate prepares for his
initiation ritual with the help of his
older brother clans will gather from 50
miles around to see if he is braver than
his opponent in a violent whipping match
I lose I will be shamed centeno Nina
because everyone from all of the
different clans will be watching back at
the village
the boys enlist their father's aid in
choosing a branch that will inflict the
most painful blow their father sharpens
the stick so it will break the
opponent's skin finally it's time to
head off to battle the pate is excited
in spite of the bloody test that awaits
him meanwhile a young Fulani woman is
undergoing her own rite of passage into
adulthood today MA day will receive a
full set of traditional facial tattoos
and become a woman ma days tattoos will
be done by a local artist Goku Rea he
readies the needles he will use to make
thousands of tiny pricks in ma day's
face
the hours long ritual will test the
girl's bravery if she cries or shows
pain then she will be shamed and the
tattooing may be delayed until she is
older before in scribing the painful
tattoo Kaku Rey paints elaborate designs
each carries a special meaning for the
Fulani eyes on her temples will allow ma
de to keep watch on her husband at all
times cow tracks symbolize prosperity
requirement the beginning is the most
painful blood begins to mix with the ink
but the artist continues after more than
three hours the work is complete
according to Fulani tradition ma de is
now a beautiful woman ready to consider
marriage ma day has finished her
initiation right but the pate is about
to face his own test the pottery learns
that his opponent will be a boy named
mati from a neighboring clan first the
Potter will whip mati three times and
then he will have to endure the same
whoever hits the other the hardest and
flinches the least when hit himself will
be declared the winner the crowd will
determine who is bravest
it is an impressive performance motty's
clan celebrates his bravery by showering
him with white talc powder and placing
coins on his forehead as a
congratulatory gesture now it is the
party's turn to be beaten
the crowd roars he barely flinched when
struck by his opponent's weaker blows
and he's won the match though Bhupati
skin is broken his spirit is not it is
burning me it really hurts that I'm full
of joy I'm very proud because I have won
the potty has endured a painful ordeal
and become an adult member of the Fulani
tribe